[موسيقى]
k
شهد شاهد فهو شهيد
[موسيقى]
محمدد انا الشهيد انا من شهد الميدان
الشاهد على ما رى في الميدان الناهض
الغاضب المتمرد الفارس المارد الثائر
المحمول على
الاعناق ثم انا المحمول على
الاعناق المغمور بالدمع والزهر
والدعاء الموجوع بالفراق الصارخ من قلب
القبر الجنه اتموا ثورتكم لا تخونوا دمي
ولا الميدان اتموا ثورتكم مازال في القصر
بعض
من جنود
[موسيقى]
السلطان السلام عليكم الثوره في بر مصر
امر لم يكن يتوقعه احد كل الوقائع كانت
تشير الى ازمه سياسيه اقتصاديه اجتماعيه
قد تنفجر غضبا وعنفا وفوضى لكنها ليست
الثوره لكنها كانت الثوره هدف جلي واضح
الشعب يريد اسقاط
النظام الشعب اسقط راس النظام فهل انتصرت
الثوره وهل بوسع 18 يوما ان تهزم اكثر من
30 عاما الخبر في مصر يفيد ان الثوره
انطلقت بدات اشتعلت لكنها لم تنتهي بعد
المعركه يا ساده ما زالت طويله والنظام
الصنم
مازال قائما والتفاصيل في البيان
التالي شهر يناير يوم 25 اعظم تاريخ ثوه
مصريه على مر السنين شباب رفع راس مصر
لفوق مش لابس طوق عاوز حقوقه الشرعيه
وطلبها بكل ذوق خد لك لفه ولف واتفرج في
مدان التحرير هتلقى وشك ابتسم قلبك قرب
يطير شباب فهم معنى الوحده اتحد عمل تغيير
قمت المصري النهارده بعد الثوره اكبر
بكتير ما تخافيش يا بلادي في عز المحنه
تحامي فينا احنا ادك رجاله نحطك فوق روسنا
وفي عينينا شكرا لكل شاب الرايه من غير ما
يخاف راجل من ضهر راجل خلى العالم بص وشاف
هي دي مصر اللي احنا
عايزينها افعل ما يفعله زوار القاهره هذه
الايام اتوجه مباشره الى ميدان التحرير
حيث وقعت
الواقع مشهد مختلف تماما عما اراده الخدي
واسماعيل عشق ميدان الشانزليزيه الباريسي
فاس في قلب القاهره مثيلا له ميدان
الاسماعيليه يتظاهر المصريون فيه ضد
الاحتلال البريطاني فيصبح اسمه بعد ثوره
يوليو عام 52 ميدان التحرير هو لم يعد
رمزا للتحرر من الاستعمار فحسب بل لكل
حركات الاحتجاج السياسيه منذ عهد عبد
الناصر وحتى الان فكتب امل دنقل عن
التحرير الكعكه الحجريه وغنى الشيخ امام
بشاير يناير الى ان اندلعت الثوره الاخيره
بص بص بص
بص
حريه
بشريه شعبيه بين لكل الامه من مواطن مش
مسؤول زمن الكرامه ابتد ه علي صوتك يلا
وقول شعبي في اشجع ناس واطيب ناس و وعقول
عمره ما وط راسه تاريخه كل العصور بعد 25
يناير
اكبر ثوره حصل في تاريخ بشريه علمنا
العالم معنى الثوره شعبيه عاش
[موسيقى]
وف اللي هينزل مش هي اللي هينزل مش هيموت
يا مصري و الصو يا مصري وعل الصوت اللي
هينزل مش هيموت اللي هينزل مش هيموت شيء
لا يتص الذي يحصي عدد المجتمعين في ميدان
التحرير مخطئ لانه اذا انت شايفهم 2 مليون
هما 2 مليون في اللحظه اللي انت شفتهم
فيها لكن في ناس خارجه وفي ناس داخله فتظل
المليون موجوده 2 مليون موجودين لكن في
حاله تكرار فتقدر تعد 10 مش تقدر تعد مش
بس تتوقف عند رقم ال 2 مليون مرحب مرحب
بالثوار مرحب مرحب بالثوار مرحب مرحب
بالثوار مرحب مرحب بالثوار هذا التدفق وده
اللي مدي وده اللي ميز الثوره عن اي ثورات
اخرى او اي حركات
استقلاليه كنا نتخوف من ان تقوم
العشوائيات بالهجوم
على الاماكن الفخمه في ضواحي القاهره او
ضواحي المدن الكبرى لكننا رايناهم يتجمعوا
معا في ميدان التحرير الغني مع
الفقير المسلم مع المسيحي المحجبه مع
السافره دي ثوره كما يعني تجلت في التحرير
كان فيها رؤساء شركات الى جانب بعمال وكان
فيها شباب
ا تحت ال 20 سنه وكان فيها
ا ناس فوق ال 70 عاما رجال ونساء على
مقاعد
متحركه ترابط في ميدان التحرير وتنام في
ميدان التحرير وكانت هناك اسر بكاملها
باطفالها رغم انه كانت هناك دبابات ورغم
انه هناك شهداء سقطوا القائد الحقيقي لهذه
الثوره هم هؤلاء الشهداء اللي عددهم يفوق
ال 600 على الا اقل شهيد بالاضافه لمن
فقدوا اعينهم واصيبوا بكسور وفي غيبوبه
ودول يتجاوزوا 1200 مصاب اثبت يا بطل اثبت
في المكان وابرا من المطر اثبت في المدال
اثبت يا بطل اذبت في المكان
واط اذبت في احنا لما كنا بننزل قبل
كده بلم توقعات توقعات التغيير كان الناس
بترفض انه اتوقع لا احنا عايزين ناكل
العيش لا احنا خايفين لا البلد بتاعتهم مش
بتاعتنا لما تونس حصل فيها الثوره ادت
للناس امل ان هي لا ده ممكن بقى ان احنا
نسخط النظام بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم ايها
المواطنون في هذه الظروف
العصيبه التي تمر بها
البلاد قرر الرئيس محمد حسني
مبارك تخليه عن منصب رئيس الجمهوريه
وكلف المجلس الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه لاداره شؤون
البلاد والله الموفق
[تصفيق]
والمستعان
حريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حريه
هما في هذه الليله احتفى المصريون بالنصر
لكن سرعان ما ادركه في الصباح ان ما سقط
ليس سوى راس النظام فيما النظام كله مازال
قائما وان استمرار النضال واجب للوصول
بالثوره الى
منتهاها المشهد ده اكتر حاجه بعنيه ويرمز
لها انه الناس عندها ادراك واضح لانه سقوط
راس النظام لا يعني سقوط النظام الشعار
الشعب يريد اسقاط النظام شعار لم يكن معني
به مبارك بس الناس مدركه انه ده ما انه
الثوره دي ما كملتش لسه الرموز موجوده
مكانها المؤسسات لسه قائمه بذاتها كما هي
القوانين والقواعد اللي بتحكم علاقه
المجتمع ده ببعضه متغيرتش فالناس لسه
مكمله مصر امانه وال سن مصر امانه امانه
والنا جمان مصر امانه واللي اخنا جمان
الحاجتين اللي حصلوا واحنا متاكدين منهم
تاكد كامل هو ما دعت اليه كفايه في بدايه
عصرها انه لا للتمديد لا للتوريث فعلا
مبارك اختفى وابنه اختفى ما عدا ذلك ما
زالت امنيات وطلبات ومطالب وتعديلات ويعني
يعني لسه لم نحقق ما نريد بالفعل رحل
مبارك ولم يرحل نظام مبارك
رحل مبارك ولم ترحل طبقه مبارك التي ظلت
تحكم مصر اكثر من 30 سنه نحن اذاء ثوره
مصريه لم تكتمل بعد وبالتالي لا نستطيع ان
نقول الان ان هذه الثوره انتصرت الثوره
تنتصر حين تحقق اهدافها بالكامل لكن
النظام مازال مستمرا باشكال مختلفه رموز
النظام ما تزال قائمه ولذلك يمكن ان تنقض
بشكل او باخر في مرحله او اخرى على الثوره
فيما يتوقع الناس او يطلق عليه
الثوره المضاده
ح ايام الثوره استنفد الناس ما في طاقتهم
وعيا وعملا فاذا ما انتصروا انصرفوا هدات
نفوسهم وفطرت همتهم الحكايه حصلت والرساله
وصل وهي اللحظه المناسبه ليبدا النظام
الذي لم يسقط بعد في العمل ويسلك كل السبل
التي يمكن ان تعيده الى الحياه او تحفظ له
بعض مكتسباته او تعرقل مسيره الثوره وتقلل
من
مكتسباتها الثوره المضاده هي مجموعه من
الافعال من قوى اصحاب مصالح ترغب في الا
تنتهي اي ثوره الى ما قامت من اجله ببساطه
شديده جدا تصورنا رده فرنسا عن الجمهوريه
بعد الثوره الفرنسيه الى امبراطوريه فهذا
بالتاكيد كان من صن ثوره
مضاده محاولات بعض الاقطاعيين بعد ثوره 52
محاولات الالتفاف ومساعده القوى
الاستعماريه او الانجليز تحديدا في عدوان
سنه 56 هذا نوع من انواع ما يسمى الثوره
المضاده عندنا مثلا ثوره مصدق والامريكان
تحدثوا كيف انه كلمه روزفل ذهب
وم حقائب مليئه بمئات الالاف من الدولارات
وكيف انه حاول يجند ناس وكيف انه استاجر
بعض المصارعين
حتى ينزلوا الى الشارع
فحرك كل من
اضر من من الثوره واستطاعوا ان هو يعيدوا
الشام مره
اخرى
في ميدان مصطفى محمود اجتمع المؤيدون
لمبارك واعتبر الميدان رمزا للذين يعارضون
الثوره وربما المتورطين في الثوره المضاده
وهم
كثر كل من
انتفعوا بالنظام
السابق صاروا في خندق الثوره
المضاده المنتفعون هؤلاء خليط من
المتنفذين رجال الاداره اللي كانوا موظفين
عاديين نعرفهم ثم تحولوا
الى مليونيرات كبار انتفعوا في كل الذين
احتكروا احتكروا السياسه او احتكروا
التجاره او احتكروا الصحافه يقفون في هذا
المربع ف ودي جيوش ليست بسيطه الشعب يريد
محبه المخروع الشعب يريد محاكمه المخروع
الشعب يريد محب الموح الشعب نظام فاسد
مستبد بناه مبارك موازن للشعب في القوه
مضاد له في الاتجاه نظام تمدد في المجتمع
المصري بشكل سرطاني مخيف له اركانه وله
قواه التي تدير المعركه بذكاء شديد معركه
الثوره المضاده القوى الاخطر في الحقيقه
التي تبدو غير ظاهره ولكنها بديهيه ايضا
هي الحزب الوطن او الحزب الحاكم اللي هو
كان عباره عن حاله اداريه تمثل ادوات
النظام التنفيذيه والفكريه في كل الاحوال
الحزب لازال قائم لازالت كوادره تحاول ان
تلملم صفوفها بشكل او باخر هو لم يكن في
حقيقه الامر حزب سياسي وانما كان تجمع
لاصحاب المصالح انا باصف هذا النظام بانه
كان تحالف الفساد والاستبداد هذا الحزب
واركانه ده د دعامه قويه جدا للثوره
المضاده ومازال وسيظل يمثل تهديد
98% من المجالس المحليه في مصر اعضاء في
الحزب الوطني في تباطؤ شديد في عمليه حل
هذا الحزب وحل هذه القيادات من دايره
صناعه القرار في
مصر الحزب الوطني دوله داخل الدوله في يده
السلطه والمال قوامه الفاسدون من رجال
الاعمال واعضاء مجلس الشعب والمهمه تمرير
الصفقات الفاسده والقوانين المشبوهه لذلك
فهو يستحق في نظر الثوار النار ولا منقذ
له ومن ثم يصبح اطلالا ومزارا للمتشه فيه
غير المدركين ربما انه مازال قائما وان
رجاله مازالوا يعملون جاهدين ضد الثوره
حلل الحزب الوطني او عدم حله مش دي القضيه
القضيه الحقيقيه هو تجميد نشاط اعضاء
الحزب الوطني السياسي لمده خمس سنين اخدوا
فرصه 30
سنه يتوقفوا تماما اظن تجميد يعني تجميد
نشاطهم السياسي مش ظلم ولا حاجه 30 سنه
نشاط سياسي خمس سنين تجميد نشاطهم السياسي
لحد ما القوى الاخرى تاخد
[تصفيق]
فرصتهم
في ربيع العرب الجمعه للثوره والموعد هو
الصلاه والمؤذن يستعذب النداء حي على
الفلاح والخطبه تتجاوز احكام الطهاره الى
احكام التطهير والى الواجب الاكيد الذي هو
النهي عن منكر استشرى في البلاد نحن الشعب
ونحن الثوره ونحن نرفض المصالحه هناك
اخطبوط هائل يعني ذي الف ذراع اسمه جهاز
مباحث امن الدوله هو الجهاز المركزي
للثوره المضاد نعرف ان نظما من نوع نظم
نظام مبارك يعني ذات ملامح مشتركه يعني
عائله تحكم جماعه من مليارديرات المار
الحرام من حولها ترتكز على قاعده امنيه
متضخمه ومتورمه التي وصلت الى حدود 1.7 من
مليون فرد اي ثلاث اضعاف حجم الجيش كان
جهاز امن الدوله الذي يعني استولى على كل
شيء في مصر بتوكيل من بيت السلطان او بيت
الرئيس بدء من تعيين الخفير الى تعيين
الوزير ومن العمده حتى رئيس الوزراء امن
الدوله يا امن الدوله امن الدوله يا امن
الدوله بره بره يا امن الدوله بره بره امن
الدوله كان مجرد ذكر اسمه يثير الرعب في
نفوس الناس جهاز امن الدوله في مصر هو
اقدم جهاز من نوعه في الشرق الاوسط تاسس
على يد الاستعمار البريطاني وحمل اسماء
متعدده القسم المخصوص القلم السياسي
المباحث العامه مباحث امن
الدوله في هذه الجمعه نادى الثوار بحله في
اليوم التالي بدا رجال امن الدوله في حرق
ما لديهم من مستندات خوفا من المسائله مما
دفع المتظاهرين الى اقتحام العديد من
مقرات امن الدوله ثم صدر قرار بحله تكوين
جهاز اخر باسم الامن الوطني قيل ان هدفه
مكافحه الارهاب جهاز امن الدوله تم حله
ولكنه لم يتغير نظامه يعني هو تحول من
جهاز امن الدوله الى جهاز الامن الوطني
احنا مش محتاجين
جهاز تاني يكافح الارهاب احنا عندنا
مخابرات عامه ومخابرات عسكريه وامن قومي
كل الناس دي بتراقب ن نجيب جهاز تاني
يراقبنا بس هم يعني عن انا فاهمه ليه
عملوه جهاز امن وطني عشان عندهم متخوف انه
عناصر امن الدوله لو اتحلت تماما واتثبت
ممكن يتحولوا الى ميليشيات فقرروا ان هم
يلمهم في مكان يعني وصرفوا لهم مرتب بس
اوكي يعني لو هي اعانه بطاله انا موافقه
بس يبقى تحت اشراف قضائي
وحقوقي ماسبيرو هو اسم عالم اثار فرنسي
كان رئيسا لهيئه الاثار المصريه وهو ايضا
اسم البنايه الشهيره التي تطل على النيل
كمقر للتلفزيون المصري ماسبيرو
للا
الرس الذي شارك في الحرب ضد الثوره منذ
اللحظه الاولى لاندلاع تقدر تبيز انتماءات
للمصريين دول اللي موجودين او الاجانب دول
جنسيات معينه واضحين هم اجانب بيكلموا
انجش ل كويس جدا مافيش حد بيتكلم غير
الانجليزيه
جوه لكن
جو اللي بيوجه النداء دلوقتي زمايلنا اللي
موجودين هم مصريين علشان
بكره اتحط لله سلوجان انه يبقى يوم
الخلاص يوم الخلاص اول عنصر بيفعل الاعلام
هو ما اسميه انا فزاعه الفوضى تحولت
تلفزيون المصري منذ يوم 25 يناير الى 11
فبراير الى اله لبث الرعب ولدي شواهد
وادله كثيره على ان هناك اتصالات مفبركه
استخدمت لاثاره الزعر بين الجمهور نمره
اثنين فزعه الجوع هذه الحكومه كانت
تصدعناش القمح يكفي سته اشهر الاحتياط
النقدي امن ويقفي احتياجات البلاد لمده 18
شهرا الان بعد ثلاثه ايام سنت نمره
لاثه فزعه الامن القومي المستباح فجاه نحن
الان نشعر ان اسرائيل عدو وان مياه النيل
تس وكان افاقي عنتيبي لم توقع في شهر مايو
2010 وقعك يوم 25 يناير رابع شيء او اليه
بتستخدم هي اليه الضغط والترهي جزء من هذه
الدعايه تعلق بالوضع الاقتصادي عموما في
مصر التحذير من كارثه اقتصاديه وهناك
مشكله كبيره في امدادات الغذاء ومشكله في
الاداء الاقتصادي ستنتج كارثه بالعكس هناك
عدد من البنوك الاستثمار العالميه
والشركات العالميه ترى في
انزياح النظام السابق فرصه اكبر لضخ
المزيد من الاستثمارات الاجنبيه لانه على
الاقل فيما يتعلق بقطاعات زي الحديد كان
فيها احتكار وبالتالي لا توجد فرصه
للاستثمار الاجنبي انه يدخل لانه هناك
اشخاص قريبه من السلطه تمنع هذا الدخول
جزء من من الثوره المضاده ده دعايه انا مش
قادره افهمها ازاي بيتقال على مبارك بعد
كل اللي حصل ده الرئيس السابق لا مبارك مش
الرئيس السابق مبارك الرئيس المخلوع ده
جزء مهم من الثوره المضاد انك تمحي حقيقه
انه خلع مش سابق مش مش مات ومش جه حد
بداله في انتخابات ده خلع من
شعبه حرق العلم الاسرائيلي في التحرير
اشاره واضحه الى ان الناس تدرك ان فتح
ابواب مصر امام الكيان الصهيوني كان ضمن
الجرائم التي ارتكبها مبارك لذا لا غرابه
اذا اراد الاسرائيليون المساهمه في الثوره
المضاده باعتبار انهم احد الاطراف
المتضرره من الثوره الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل كانت تتعامل مع العالم العربي
باعتباره جثه هامده تفعل ما تشاء فيها
الامر الان اختلف فلا بد كان هؤلاء يعودون
النظر في مخطط ل دفاعا عن مصالحهم وانا
شايف انه هم طبعا يسان لابد ان يساندوا
القوى الثوره المضاده اسرائيل تدرك تماما
ان نجاح الثوره المصريه معناه ان هناك
اداره جديده للصراع العربي الاسرائيلي ان
هناك موقف جديد جديد من من اسرائيل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا تدرك ان
مصر عندما تكون مستقله ومتحرره ربما تعيد
انتاج
النصر يعني زخم الاستقلال الوطني
والانتماء العربي لمصر ولكن من خلال
مؤسسات ديمقراطيه واليات ديمقراطيه واظن
ان هذا يشكل خطر كبير جدا على المصالح
الامريكيه والمصالح الاسرائيليه الشعب
يريد تطهير البلاد
الشعب يريد نير البلاد الحزب الوطني
والفاسدون من رجال الاعمال وجهاز امن
الدوله والاعلام الرسمي وقوى خارجيه هي
اطراف يخشى على الثوره من جانبها وهي تمثل
اركان الثوره المضاده ومن المؤكد انها لن
تستسلم بسهوله وان لها وسائلها
المتعدده قد يكون غياب الامن او استمرار
غياب
الامن احد الاساليب في تغذيه الثوره
المضاده انه الشعب يفضل عوده الامن على
استكمال الثوره يحس بعدم الامان في
المراحل
القادمه المال على سبيل المثال ممكن ان
يكون احد اساليب الاساليب التي تستخدم في
تغذيه الثوره
[موسيقى]
المضاده
ايها المسلمون
والاكبار يا ابناء مصر هذا يوم ابناء مصر
جميعا ليس يوم المسلمين وحدهم اناديهم من
هذا المنبر ومن هذا الميدان ميدان التحرير
بل هو منذ اليوم يجب ان يسمى ميدان
شهداء ثوره 25 يناير اثار حضور الشيخ يوسف
القرضاوي صلاه الجمعه في التحرير حفيظه
البعض غير ان خطبته حملت العديد من
الرسائل الموجهه لعل اهمها كان المعني
بشان الوحده الوطنيه يقول العارفون بالامر
ان نظام مبارك الذي لم يسقط بعد كان يعتمد
على امرين لالهاء الناس الفتنه الطائفيه
وكره القدم
هناك معلومات انه عناصر من مباحث امن
الدوله ذهبت الى دوائر
قبطيه وحرضت على التحرك في هذه الفتره
بالذات من اجل التظاهر احتجاجا على الماده
الثانيه من الدستور التي تنص على ان مبادئ
الشريعه الاسلاميه هي المصدر الرئيسي
للتشريع ايضا ليس حبا في سواد عيون
العلمانيه وانما استغلالا
لهموم الاقباط المصريين خلق حاله من
الفوضى
الان اما كره القدم فحدث ولا حرج ولعل
الشغب المخطط له الذي وقع في المباراه
الاخيره مع تونس يشير ايضا باصابع الاتهام
الى رجال الثوره المضاده الثوره ثوره
مصريه لا شرقيه ولا غربيه في ثوره حق وحق
لا شرقيه ولا غربيه في كل الاحوال ثمت
مخاوف اخرى على الثوره ثمت تحديات اخرى في
مواجهه الثوره انقسام الشباب الذين فجروا
الثوره لان الثوره لم يكن لها راس ولم يكن
لها رئيس
ولم يقضها حزب معين وبالتالي قادتها
جماعات مختلفه ومتنوعه عندما تؤسس لنظام
سياسي جديد ليس بالضروره ان تتفق هذه
الجماعات وبالتالي قد يؤدي الانقسام الى
عرقله الثوره ومنعها من تحقيق اهدافها في
نهايه المطاف انا بسميه وكلاء الثوره او
من نصبوا نفسهم مكلا عن الثوره يتحدثوا
عنها و ويحرصوا دائما في وسائل الاعلام
المختلفه على ان يجدوا اي جهد للاخرين
وينكروا اي فضل لاي تيار او اي حزب او
اي شخص ساهم في صنع التراكم الذي حدثت به
ثوره وده وده قد يكون حماسهم للثوره قد
يكون حرصهم وانا مش مش بستدعي سوء النيه
او سوء القصد لا نستطيع ان ندعي اننا
نتحدث باسم الثوره الثوره صنعها شعب لم
يصنع شباب الثوره قام بها هذا الشعب
العظيم الثوره دي ما كانتش صوره شباب دي
كانت صوره شعب احنا شفنا الرجال اكبر من
من من ابي وامي معانا في الميدان شفنا
الاطفال شفنا السيدات دي كانت صوه امه تحي
مصر تح مصر تحي مصرع راسك فوق انت مصري
ارفع راسك فوق انت مصري ارفع راسك
احنا
مصر احنا
مصري
[تصفيق]
احص فزاعه الاخوان استخدمها النظام قبل
الثوره وخلالها وها هو يفعل ذات الامر
الان لارباك الصفوف واحداث الفتنه بين
الصور
[موسيقى]
اقسم بالله العظيم اقسم بالله العظيم لو
عدت بي الايام لا اكتفيت بتعليم الدين
القويم وتفرغت لتعليم 100 شاب اقابل بهم
الله يوم القيامه ولا شيء غير
ذلك ولكن الايام الماضيه لا تعود يا فضيله
المرشد لذلك خلق الله الدم يا عبد
العزيز لذلك خلق الله ندم
من كان يتوقع وهو يشاهد مسلسل الجماعه على
شاشه التلفزيون المصري ان تتغير الاحوال
وتتبدل الاوضاع ويصبح الحزب الوطني الحاكم
بمثابه الحزب المحظور فيما الاخوان
المسلمون يخرجون بكل قوه من الحظر
والاعتقال الى العلانيه والعمل السياسي
العام مر انها احدى ثمرات الثوره التي لم
يشاركوا في ايامها الاولى ده خطا نحن
وقعنا ف ولازم لما نغلط نقول احنا وقعنا
في الخطا والخطا واقع لسوء تقدير للموقف
يجب ان اعترف به وهو نفسه سوء التقدير
الذي حدث في 2005 لان كان ممكن هذا وقت
كان مناسب لاسقاط المصام لو اننا تحركنا
مع شعبنا وهو نفسه الخطا الذي وقعنا فيه
نتيجه سوء التقدير في سنه 2008 عند
الموقف
الغير وطني والغير قومي والغير عربي
والغير اسلامي لنظام مبارك تجاه الحرب
الصهيونيه على غزه يوم ان ذهب البعض
الاخوه الاعزاء لمقابله عمر سليمان دون
عوده لمؤسسات الجماعه و مجلس الشورى
المختص بمثل هذه القضايا الهامه انا اعلنت
ان هذا خطا هذا سوء تقدير
ايضا ثم اخطاء مقبوله ثم اخطاء اخرى لا
يمكن ان يتحملها المجتمع المصري خصوصا اذا
طالت صميم ثورته اذا كنا نسعى لتاسيس نظام
ديمقراطي جديد قد يكون تيار مثل تيار
الاخوان اذا
ا سيطر عليه المحافظون داخل الاخوان وليس
الليبراليون داخل الاخوان قد يؤدي هذا الى
عرقله التطور الديمقراطي لا يجوز النظر
لهذه التخوفات بانها فيها قدر من التزيد
ولا يجب النظر له بالاهمال الامر الثاني
ان احنا اجب علينا يا اخوان واننا الذين
صرنا مع شعبنا نا ضد نظام قديم ان نصور
على نظامنا الحالي يجب ان يتم حل كافه
المستويات الاداريه في الاخوان المسلمين
والتي شكلت في اوضاع غير طبيعيه وبالتالي
نتجت عنه قيادات غير عاديه مش الطبيعيه
فانا بقول من ضمن الذي يجعل الناس تثق في
اعلاناتنا وكلامنا وتصريحات ان احنا بنقول
لهم احنا بنمارس هذا على نفسنا نحن نتفاهم
هذه المخاوف وجهناها وقبلنا برحابه صدر
وبسياسة منا الرئاسه القادمه قلنا اننا لن
نسعى الى اغلبيه برلمانيه في البرلمان
القادم قلنا اننا لن نريد اكثر لا نريد
اكثر من ثلث المقاعد في البرلمان القادم
قلنا اننا نريد ان يكون هناك قائمه
برلمانيه موحده لنا مع كل اطياف العمل
السياسي في الانتخابات انا اقول بكل وضوح
ان العوده الى الكلام عن فزاعه الاخوان هو
استمرار للنظام
القديم قيادات الاخوان حرست على ارسال
تطمينات في اتجاهات متعدده ومنها فهم
الجماعه لشكل الدوله المدنيه الدوله
المدنيه هي دوله كل مواطنيها يتمتع فيها
الجميع بحقوق متساويه وفق دستور عصري يحقق
التوازن بين السلطات الدوله التي فيها
الامه مصدر السلطه هي التي تولي الحكام هي
التي تراقبهم هي التي تحاسبهم هي التي
تعزلهم وفق اليات دستوريه وقانونيه واضحه
ومحدده
هي الدوله التي لا يستاثر فيها احد بمغن
من الحكم بل الحكم فيها عبء يريد الحاكم
او يكون الحاكم في اجير عند الشعب ووكيل
عن الامه وليس محتكرا للسلطه ما دور رجال
الدين في هذه الدوله هل لهم الحق في ان
يصدروا الاحكام
السياسيه علماء الدين
المسلمين الاسلام لا يعرف رجال دين ورجال
الدين الكهنوتي في المسيحيين هم مواطنون
لهم حقوق المواطنه ولكن ليس لهم الا حق
النصح والارشاد او التوجيه عن بعد او
يكونوا اعضاء اذا ارادوا في البرلمان حق
المواطنه يعطيهم الحق ان يكونوا اعطاء في
البرلمان دون ميزه على
احد مهما كان من الاخوان يجب ان ننسى انهم
لا يحتكرون وحدهم المشهد الاسلامي في مصر
وان تيارات اخرى صاعده سوف تنافس على
حصتهم في الشارع المصري
منح الحريه لكل الاحزاب ان تتشكل سيؤدي
الى تشكيل اكثر من تيار اسلامي
وبالتالي سيدرك المواطن المصري انه ليس
هناك طرح اسلامي واحد وليس هناك اسلام
سياسي واحد وانما هناك رؤى متعدده وهي رؤى
بشريه وليست رؤى دينيه كما انه في
اسلاموفوبيا
تخوف من الاسلام كده هناك ايضا اخوان
وفوبيا بمعنى انه خلينا اقول انه اولا في
هذا المشهد الحاصل الاخوان تصرفوا
بمسؤوليه كبيره الحقيقه لم يتصرفوا كاخو
ولكنهم شاركوا شاركوا في كل الاحداث
باعتبارهم
مواطنين ضاقوا زرعا بالنظام وانا استغرب
احيانا لانه في ناس قبضت لتطبيق العلاقات
مع اسرائيل ورافضه تبيع العلاقات مع
الاخوان لل المؤسف ايضا والمدهش انه ناس
بتتكلم على ديمقراطيه وتبدا بدعوه الى
الاقصاء واح
ا واح
ا مهما كان الاختلاف الحاصل في الشارع
المصري تجاه الاخوان فان الجميع يثني على
دورهم الرئيسي في الدفاع عن التحرير فيما
تعارف عليه الناس باسم موقعه الجمل حين
دفع نظام مبارك البلط
الى ميدان التحر وهاجموا المتظاهرين
بالرصاص والزجاجات الحارقه بشهاده الجميع
كان الاخوان اكثر من دافع عن الميدان
واكثر من سقط له شهداء في ذلك
[موسيقى]
اليوم
المحاكمه المحاكمه المحاكمه المحاكمه
المحاكمه لل العصابه اللي حاكم
الع بطء العدل ظلم وحتى تكتمل الثوره وحتى
لا تظل نصف ثوره فتموت يبقى التحرير هو
الحل حق قلنا ما طالبنا حق قلنا ما طالبنا
التباطؤ مش عاجبنا التباطؤ مش عاجبنا جمله
من الانتقادات موجهه الى من يدير دفه
الحكم في البلاد القوات المسلحه المصريه
هي من يفعل ذلك الان قوات المسلحه المصريه
هي لمن لا يعلم خط احمر لا يقبل المساس به
الثوار يفهمون ذلك لكنهم يؤمنون بان
النظام القديم مازال قويا ومتماسكا وقادرا
على الالتفاف على القوات المسلحه وعرقله
ادائه الجيش حركته بطيئه جدا بتهرب الناس
الحراميه واحنا مش عايزين نقول اكتر من
كده ليست هناك رؤيه تح حكم اداره المرحله
الانتقاليه لان الجيش هو الذي يسيطر على
اداره هذه المرحله ولذلك انا طلبت ان يكون
هناك مجلس رئاسي اغلبه من المدنيين هناك
تباطؤ يوحي بالتواطؤ وهذا راجع ببساطه لان
هذه الثوره لم توجد لها قياده مطابقه
فالنتيجه ان وجد المجلس العسكري كمنط
عازله في مسافه يعني
خلاف ما بين المجلس عسكري يعني لها علاقه
بما جرى على الجيش المصري خلال 30 سنه من
حيث الافراط في الامتيازات للرتب الاكبر
بعد رتبه العقيد اضافه لتدخلات اخرى تاثير
الضغط ل كانبي ديفيد ثم المعونه الامريكيه
الضامنه والمعونه العسكريه كانت هناك
خطوات هي خطوات قد تكون متباطئ ولكن ما
يكفيني انها حتى الان معظمها في الاتجاه
الصحيح وان بدا بعضها به قدر من الانتكاس
على هذه الخطوات الصحيحه ين رافي جايين
فينا سلاح راجعين راجعين رفعين قياه نصر
سالمين سالمين حفين ب عبد الله جدرين
جدرين وافين حياه الله شك يا
بلدي كرمت كل عام وتحديدا في شهر اكتوبر
تشرين يستدعي المصريون من ذاكرتهم وقائع
النصر المجيد الذي حققته قواتهم المسحه
حين عبرت الهزيمه وعبرت قناه السويس وحررت
سيناء وهو الحدث الذي يجعل المصريين
يتحدثون بحذر في اي شان يمس القوات
[موسيقى]
المسلحه نحن لم نكن نعتقد ان في هذا البلد
من يمتلك هذه القوه وهذه الهيبه وهذه
الحكمه وهذا الرجب بعد كل التدمير الذي
حدث في ال عاما الماضيه لكن لا تنسى ان
القوات المسلحه المصريه اتت من على يسار
النظام السابق ولا تنسى ان قادتها كانوا
معينين من قبل الرئيس مبارك وربما اقسمه
قصم الولاء له في وقت من الاوقات ولا تنسى
ايضا انها جزء من النسيج الاجتماعي
والسياسي والاداري المصري وربما اعتراها
بعض ما اعترى بقيه المؤسسات المؤسسه
العسكريه نفسها ربما يكون من بينها رجال
لا تريد للثوره ان تنتصر في واقع الامر
على الرغم من ان المؤسسه العسكريه لعبت
دورا مهما في حمايه الثوره وبالتالي ضحت
بالرئيس واجبرته على التخلي عن منصبه ولكن
في مرحله من المراحل قد تعرقل هي او تحد
من سرعه اندفاع الثوره نحو تحقيق مطالبها
لما المجلس الاعلى القوات المسلحه يقول ان
احنا مش طامعين في الحكم وان احنا عايزين
فتره انتقاليه احنا موافقين على ذلك وهنس
وموافقين على ده بس انا متخوف جدا من يعني
يعني في حاجات هم بطيئين فيها وعايزه سرعه
وفي حاجات هم مستعجلين فيها وعايزه بطء دي
عايزه عايزه عايزه مستشارين عايزه مدنيين
لو ان هناك مجلس رئاسه مدني يحمل هذا
العبق عن الجيش لان دي مش شغله الجيش
الجيش يحمل الديمقراطيه واحمل الحريه ولكن
هو لا يدير الدوله ولا دلاب الدوله وتبقى
جنب المجلس الرئاسه حكومه تكنوقراط زي
الحكومه الموجوده
الان تفشت عناصر الفساد في مرافق الدوله
بدرجه خطيره اساءت الى سمعه مصر في الداخل
والخارج فقمنا بحركت السلميه معتمدين على
الله وعلى تاييد شعب مصر الكريم عام 2 كان
الجيش هو من قام بالثوره والشعب ايده
الجيش والشعب حكمل المشوار في الخ من
يناير كانون الثاني كان الشعب هو من قام
بالثوره والجيش
[تصفيق]
ايده ويجب ان يؤخذ ذلك في الاعتبار عند
تقييم دور الجيش خصوصا من قبل القيادات
الشابه
للثوره الانطباعات الاولى انه يستخدم نفس
لغه النظام اللغه
الابويه وانكم عليكم ان تثقوا بنا
ارجعوا بيوتكم واحنا هنحقق المطالب احنا
فناها هم لسه بيتكلموا شويه فكره لا احنا
جايين نتحاور بس والشباب كانوا بيسوا لا
احنا عندنا مطالب وعايزين نرد دي اول
ملحوظه ملحوظه الثانيه ان احنا بنتكلم مع
شخصيات نستشعر من خلالها انها
عندها احترام للثوره واحترام للشهداء
واحترام للجانب الوطني ولكن هناك اختلاف
في فكره الخطوات هم خطواتهم من وجد نظرنا
بطيئه وهم خطواتهم هم محافظين على الرتم
البط ده عندنا معركه اساسيه اسمها الفساد
السياسي وهي الحاجه اللي برض هم مش مش
عارفين يعني ينقطو مننا ههم عايزين فساد
مالي حاجه بادله في حاجه اسمها فساد سياسي
دي جريمه
مش مش كلمه مجازيه جريمه الناس تحسب عليها
علير احنا سكتنا عليكم
كير التحرير في كل مناسبه يجدد المجلس
العسكري عهده بالحفاظ على الثوره فيما ترى
قطاعات واسعه من الناس ان بطاه الشديد
وتردده في اتخاذ قرارات حاسمه يمنح النظام
القديم فرصه ذهبيه لمحو اثار جرائمه
وتهريب امواله واعاده تنظيم صفوفه ومن ثم
فان الثوره مستمره وكذلك الثوره المضاده
احنا في حاله
اشبه بحرب
استنزاف وح حرب الاستنزاف بطبيعتها هي حرب
طويله هي ليست حرب تنتهي في ايام او في
اسابيع هي حرب شهور هي حرب سنين تريد ان
تقتلع من داخل المجتمع المصري اسوا ما كان
فيه واكثر ما حوله الى اقطاعيات مملوكيه
هذه الحرب ستستمر الى شهور ولكن اهم علاقه
فيها ان يبقى الجيش والشعب في طرف واحد
واضح يعلموا يقينا من هو الطرف المقابل
لنا
حرب استنزاف والتحرير ميدان رئيسي لها
يجتمع الثوار كل جمعه يجددون الاعلان عن
مطالبهم يصرون على ان تحقق الثوره كامل
اهدافها وان تصل الى منتهاها يعلنون صراحه
لن يخدعنا احد ولن يسرق الثوره احد ولن
يقفز عليها احد لس الثوره في
فيما المثبتون من رجال الثوره المضاده
يجاهرون باعلان ضيقهم واعتراضهم على
استمرار التظاهرات ثوره يناير لساها ثوره
يناير لسه تم بشعبنا فاير لسه تم الشعب ن
قالوا لنا رجعوا البيت من اول خطبه لمبارك
فم رجعنا البيت فمبارك مشي قالوا لنا ما
تتظاهر عشان شفيق ف تظاهرنا فشفي مشي
قالوا لنا ماله امن الدوله ماتحلوش ف
تظاهرنا فحل يعني
هم مش مهمين خالص دي يعني كورال كده بيغني
في الخلفيه اغنيه سخيفه مالهاش معنى
هتتصلح الاغنيه دي مع تصليح الاعلام
المصري محتاج اولا محاسبه المسؤولين عن
اطلاق الرصاص الحي على المواطنين المصريين
وقتل ابنائنا وبناتنا مطلوب محاكمه عاجله
للمسؤولين عن ترك الشعب المجتمع المصري
مكشوفا امام معتاد الاجرام والبلطجيه في
28 يناير مطلوب اكتساس البيئه السياسيه
التي خلفها النظام القطع في 300 او 350
جريمه قتل
عمد مع سبق الاصرار ومع الترصد بالاضافه
الى الاف من جرائم من جنايه الشروع في
القتل لان كل من اصيب بطلق ناري ولم يمت
او استشهد كان قد شرع في قتله لكنه نجع
لاسباب لا دخله لاراده من اطلق النار فلما
يبقى قدامك الاف من جرائم القتل لم يحكم
على مسؤول واحد فيها ده شيء خوف واحد يعني
محاكمه الرئيس المخلوع وعائلته وجماعه
مليارديرات المال الحرام المحيطه به والتي
شفطت ثروه الشعب المصري ونهبت موارده
اثنين اقامه حكومه كفاءات فنيه ثلاثه حل
الحزب الوطني وتسليم مقراته وممتلكاته
اربعه ح حل المجالس المحليات 53 ال في
مجالس المحليات هم القاعده الواسعه للفساد
وليس طبيعيا ان يحل مجلسي الشعب والشورى
وتبقى
المحليات هو التحرير لا
يهدا مشهد ليس كمثله مشهد الميدان كما
البرلمان محل للحوار والتعبير وعي سياسي
وانضباط في السلوك وثوره مستمره حتى النصر
ميدان التحريم ما بقاش هو الميدان دلوقتي
اللي معروف ان هو بيوصل الواحد من وسط
البلد للقصر
العيني للزمالك لمصر الجديده ده بقى ميدان
هو اللي وصل مصر
كلها لمرحله جديده من من الحريه ومن
الديمقراطيه اصبح في مشروعيه دلوقتي
مشروعيه الشارع مشروعيه ميدان التحرير وهم
قالوا كده في كل احاديثهم اذا ما نفذنا
حاجه ميدان التحرير موجود مش هيروح ولذلك
احنا بنقف في ميدان التحرير ونطالب كل
اسبوع ده دي دي دي قصه
ثوره غير مسبوقه في التاريخ وغير مسبوقه
في اي دوله من دول العالم وانا اعتقد انها
سوف تدرس انك انت بتقف كل يوم جمعه
تحاسب المسؤولين فوق تقول له انت نفذت لي
ايه وما نفذت ليش ايه وعايزين ننفذ ما
تبقى هو التحرير لا يهدا يستعيد ذكريات
ايام الثوره ويحلم بان تكون دوله
هي ما كانت عليه دوله التحرير صوتي هيعلى
كمان وكمان الاعلام بيعدم ليه ما حدش
يكلمني دلوقتي على على على مطالب اباطه
اباط ايه مطالب مصريين كلنا نطالب ومن
خلال مطالب المصريين هتتحل كل المطالب
الاخرى هو ده السياق الجديد دلوقتي هي دي
الحياه الجديده دلوقتي هي دي مصر الجديده
مشهد الشاب الذي وقف بدون ادنى تفكير امام
عربه المياه كي يوقفها في شارع الاصر
العيني هذا الشاب اقبله قدميه شاب اخر يوم
تنحي مبارك صديق اسمه حسين فقد عينيه في
الثوره ونحن نحضن بعض ونبارك ونهنئ قال لي
عيني مراحتش هدر في هذه اللحظه ادركت
تماما ان الثوره حققت شيئا مهم لهذا الشاب
الذي فقد عيني وارجع لنا جميعا حريه
وكرامه عندما كنا نقيم صلوات مسيح ح شفت
قدامي واحده ست مقبه وواحده ست محجبه
بيقولوا معانا
التراتيل فدمعت عيني وماقدرتش استحمل هذا
الموقف المؤثر للغايه وعرفت انه الفتنه
اللي بين الشعب المصري دي فتنه مفتعله
وبعد ما خلصنا قابلني رجل ملتحي وقال لي
احنا ما كناش انا ما كنتش متخيل ان احنا
قريبين من بعض كده انا
حاسه ب عندي حب ل بلد فظيعه عندي حاجه ان
انا عايزه اعملها انا ما كانش عندي اي
ميول سياسيه ا عايزي زي اي بشتغل وبخرج
وبسافر ما كنتش عايزه اعمل حاجه للبلد ال
20 يوم اللي مريت بيهم في مدان التحرير
غيروا حياتي تماما يعني وغيروا حياه الشعب
المصري كله هو التحرير لا يهدا من هنا
يبدا عصر مصر والى هنا يعود المغيبون
والمهاجرون وفيه تسترد الحريه والكرامه
واليه يرنو الاخوه الاشقاء الحالمون
بالوحده والرفاهيه ومنه يبدا الطريق نحو
ارض تان من الاحتلال
البغيض وبه تكتمل الثوره وتحقق منتهاها
وغير ذلك تكون الخيانه لمن سقط شهيدا في
اي ثوره اطلاق النار والموت يحدث تراجع
لدى من يطلق عليه النار احنا الثوره دي
بدات تتشبث بطل طها عند سقوط الشهداء انا
عمري ما كنت اتخيل ابدا وانا في على كوبري
15 مايو اني اشوف شباب بنطلونه ساقط كده
ولابسين يعني فانكي كده ولما زميله يقع
جنبه يروح جاري على
الرصاص والقنابل جايه عليهم والرصاص جاي
عليهم وهم متقدمين ولما يقع منهم ناس
يفضلوا متقدمين حدش فيهم بيجري عمري ما
كنت يعني عماله ابص
اقول
كانهم جايين من السما
مثلا وشفت لما كنا لما الناس كانت بتصلي
وابتدوا يضربوا ميه ورصاص على المصلين فال
المسيحيين دخلوا واحد مسيحي دخل وفرد
ايديه قدام قدام الامام عشان ياخد مكانه
الرصاص مسحيين كتير دخلوا يصلوا معانا ومش
عارفين يصلوا فبقوا عمالين ايه يعني مش
عارفين يسجدوا ولا يركعوا بقوا ينزلوا على
الارض ويطلعوا كده عشان ياخدوا الرصاص
معانا انا ما كنتش اتخيل ابدا ان يعني
الشهداء اللي راحوا دول ولا واحد فيهم مات
بظهره كلهم ماتوا موته مشرفه كلهم ماتوا
بوشهم كلهم ماتوا وهم رايحين وبيجوا ما
حدش فيهم كان
بيجري ولا واحد فيهم مش شهيد ان شاء الله
كلهم
شه
احر
شهداء
احرار
ابرار ثوار مصر الكتف في الكتف والقدم في
القدم والهدف هو هو ذات الهدف الشعب يريد
اسقاط النظام كامل النظام كل النظام وذلك
هو منتهى الثوره السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
احرار
شه
ابرار